jen comes to a mysterious hypnotherapist
to help her overcome her depression and
after going to some sessions she
realizes that he is manipulating her
mind so today on cinema recap i'll show
you hypnotic
the film begins with a woman who is very
scared because she feels that someone is
following her she calls the police but
no one answers the phone she gets on an
elevator when she suddenly receives a
call from a stranger at that moment the
elevator stops and the woman sees how
the walls start closing in until they
end up crushing her then we see another
woman who has just arrived at a party
where a friend introduces her to a
therapist he greets her and gives her
his card in case she ever needs his
services then the woman named jen goes
outside for a moment to take a breath
when suddenly her ex-boyfriend who is
also at the party approaches her and
says that he misses her a lot jen tells
him that it was not his fault that they
broke up and that she is just a bit
confused then the ex-boyfriend asks her
if he can take her home jen accepts and
they end up in bed jen talks to her
friend the next day about what happened
last night and her friend tells her that
she should go to therapy with the doctor
she met at a party so that her life can
improve because it seems that she's lost
jen ends up going to see the therapist
and tells him that she does not feel
motivated to do things and that she also
drinks a lot and does not sleep well the
therapist asks her what is the reason
for all this but she does not know for
sure the therapist asks her to tell him
about her ex-boyfriend and jen tells him
that they had a life together they were
getting married and that they were going
to have a baby but then she had an
abortion and therefore she could no
longer maintain her relationship with
him so they broke up the therapist says
she needs a hypnotherapy session since
that's helpful for people who have
suffered trauma jen accepts and the
therapist begins the session by asking
jen to relax on a couch after one hour
jen wakes up and does not remember what
happened during that time but the doctor
tells her that she did good three months
later we see that chen has made a lot of
progress and has even found a new job
jen does yoga with her friend and tells
her how well she's doing that night she
goes to sleep and dreams that she is
sleeping with the doctor in an unknown
house but she wakes up and just forget
about it the next day she runs into the
doctor in the shopping center and they
meet for dinner that night jen asks him
about his life and the doctor answers
that he had a partner but she died the
doctor asks how she is doing with his
ex-boyfriend to which jen replies that
she has been avoiding him but the doctor
advises her to talk to him to clarify
things once and for all then calls her
ex-boyfriend then invites him to dinner
then she goes to the store to buy things
for dinner when suddenly someone calls
her on the phone and at that moment she
becomes paralyzed and we see that she
goes from being in the store to sitting
in the dining room of her house jen gets
up from the chair and looks around when
suddenly she hears someone complaining
in the bathroom and when she goes she
realizes that her ex-boyfriend is
choking because he ate something he is
allergic to at the hospital jen and her
friend are worried about her
ex-boyfriend's health but also because
she doesn't remember anything that
happened in the course of the store
until the accident but a friend tells
her that maybe it's because she's in
shock although jen knows that it's not
that jen goes to therapy and tells her
doctor that she is worried about that
lost time in her memory but the
therapist tells her not to worry benjen
asks him if it is not a consequence of
the hypotherapist and the doctor answers
that if she doubts him she will not
overcome her fears and therefore she
will not be cured soon so he asks her to
trust him jen goes home and when she was
in the kitchen she realizes that there
is a ticket on the table of what she
bought in the store that night so she
takes it and sees that she bought the
ingredient to which her ex-boyfriend is
allergic to genelec super things and
finds the ingredient there so at that
moment she begins to remember what
happened after being in the store the
doctor called her on the phone and told
her to light the fire as if it were in
order so after the culture and went to
the store and bought the ingredients and
then made the food and asked the
ex-boyfriend to eat with her but all
this as if she were under the influence
of hypnosis jen starts to investigate
what are the effects of hypnotherapy and
realizes that there are some cases in
which the therapist takes advantage of
this to make his patients do all kinds
of things and she also realizes that
there have even been crimes so she
prints out all this information and
takes it to her friend however she tells
her that she does not think it is real
or that at least it is not the case to
the therapist they are both going to jen
tells her that she is having the same
symptoms as other people who have been
manipulated and also tells her that she
has investigated the therapist finding
out that he does not have employees or
in address where he sleeps that there is
only his department where he gives the
fair piece then she tells her that she
investigated the background of the
therapist and that in the past he had a
patient who denounced him for harassment
so they gave him a restraining order and
two days later the girl appeared at due
to heart problems but that she believes
that the doctor had something to do with
it finally jen tells her friend about
the doctor's call in the store and what
she did without consent so the friend
ends up believing her and they both go
to talk to the policemen who took the
case to the girl who died because of the
therapist jen tells the policeman that
she is going to therapy with the same
doctor and that she suspects that he is
doing the same thing he did to the other
girl the policeman shows her some
photographs of how the girl died he also
shows them some recordings of a security
camera where they can see what happened
to the girl in her last moments we see
that the woman is the same from the
beginning of the film who was crushed by
the walls of the elevator then we
realized that the call that the woman
received when entering the elevator was
from the doctor and that probably at
that moment he manipulated the woman's
mind so that she thought that the
elevator was crushing her so the woman
ended up dying of fright and other
people thought it was a heart attack the
two friends get scared and go home but
jen decides to see the therapist for
hypnotherapy session but in this case
she leaves her cell phone recording
audio to see what happens when she is
hypnotized so at the end of the session
jen goes to her car and listens to the
recording and realizes that the
therapist asked her some questions and
found out about evie thing because when
she is hypnotized she tells the whole
truth so she told him that she was
recording that she knew about the woman
from the past that she had gone to the
police and that a friend also knew jen
calls her friend to warn her that the
doctor knows everything but a friend
does not listen to her because she was
waiting for the calls some investors and
answers an unknown number thinking that
it is them but it's the doctor he gives
her an order and the friend begins to
see that she has a spider in her sweater
and she gets so scared that she ends up
having a car accident the detective goes
to talk to chen and they chat for a
moment about the things the doctor did
and then he leaves jen takes some
documents that the detective left her
when suddenly there is a knock on the
door so she opens it thinking that it
was the police officer again however it
was the doctor so she tries to close the
door but he manages to enter and gives
her the order to stop moving causing jen
to be completely paralyzed the doctor
approaches jen and tells her that
everything he does it's because he loves
her and that she should not be afraid of
him then he tells her that he's going to
go after the detective because he is
only going to mess things up and then he
leaves after telling jen that she could
move again jen closes the door and tries
to call the detective to warn him but he
does not answer because he has the phone
unloaded then we see the policeman
calmly watching tv when suddenly a woman
who is also a patient of the therapist
comes out from one of the furniture and
attacks him with a knife because she is
being controlled by the doctor the
detective fights against this woman and
ends up beating her although he is
seriously injured jen visits the
detective at the hospital and tells him
that she has an idea to end the doctor
she tells him that she will assist
another therapist to help her remember
what happened in the sessions with the
doctor so they can have evidence to put
him into jail then jen goes to a lady
who's a therapist who will help her
remember
however when the doctor tries to
hypnotize chen she begins to not be able
to breathe jen sees some memories and
then wakes up very upset the therapist
explains that the doctor put locks on
her so that no other therapist could
hypnotize her then the therapist offers
chen to put a trigger on her mind that
will help her in case the doctor tries
to hypnotize her again later jen goes
home and starts investigating with the
information she saw while she was
hypnotized and realizes that the doctor
had a teacher who taught him everything
he knows so jen decides to look for this
teacher when she arrives at the house
where the teacher lives she meets the
doctor he tells her that his teacher was
actually his father and that he has
already died then he orders chen to go
to sleep jen wakes up after a while and
calls the detective to tell him
everything and also tells him that she
is locked in the department where the
doctor gives his therapies so the
detective sends several policemen to
rescue chen at that moment the doctor
enters and tells chen that she looks a
lot like his old wife the police
officers come to rescue chen but they
realize that there is no one there jen
wakes up again and realizes that she is
actually in the doctor's house and that
he played with her mind so she would
give the wrong address to the police
then the detective who was on his way to
where the other policemen were realizes
the deception and changes his course
towards the therapist's house to rescue
china the doctor tells jen who's
paralyzed that he implanted false
memories in her so that she would think
that she was his former wife and that's
why chen had dreams about him the
policeman arrives and makes noise with
the door so the doctor realizes that he
is inside the house and decides to go
look for him the detective and the
doctor run into each other and begin to
fight at that moment jen manages to
remove the paralysis from her body and
runs to help the policeman however when
she arrives the doctor orders her to
sleep jen gradually falls asleep but
first she takes the gun and points it at
the doctor and ends up shooting without
knowing which of the two she hit then
jen wakes up next to the policeman he
tells her that she hit the doctor and
that everything is over jen hugs the
detective and at that moment the police
calls her my love at that moment jen
remembers that the other therapist told
her through hypnosis that if she heard
those words she would come out of the
hypnosis she was in jen then comes back
to reality and realizes that who she is
really hugging is the doctor so she
separates and hits him and then runs out
of there she goes to where the detective
is lying who tells her that he has
another weapon in the ankle jen takes
the gun and when the doctor comes she
kills him a month goes by and we see
that chen is making progress that her
ex-boyfriend is improving in health and
that the detective received a promotion
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps of the best filler movies i
hope you're doing okay and i'll see you
in the next video bye